[موسيقى]
في هذا المكان يجتمع اكثر من 1300 نوع من
الحيوانات الاليفه والمفترسه حديقه
الحيوان او رياض ذو المجدده بالكامل
تستقبل زوارها الكبار والصغار لاستمتاع في
مشاهده مختلف الحيوانات
بقى في حتى حيوانات جديده بقى في فعاليات
بقى في الامور بصراحه هنا بقت طيبه جدا
جدا
يتفوق عليها الاطفال الذين تعاونوا للتغلب
عليها كما تتيح لهم فرصه اطعام الزرافه من
الاعلى ضمن تجربه التواصل مع الحيوانات
انا كل اللي عجبني النمر الابيض
اتفرجت عليه وحبيته وهو يعني كان في بنت
وكان في ولد فحبيتهم الاثنين
العروض المسرحيه التي تجسد عالم الطبيعه
من مختلف البلدان اضافه الى تلوين وجوه
الاطفال على شكل الحيوانات المفضله لديها
من الرياض تشاهد المتروك بالعربيه